welcome back now that we hopefully have
a little bit of an intuition of what a
limit is or finding the limit of a
function is let's do some problems some
of these these are but you might
actually see on your your exams or when
you're actually trying to solve a a
general limit problem so let's say let's
so let's say that what is the limit
once again my pin is not working let's
see it's working what is the limit as X
approaches let's say negative 1 and let
me see what's a good let's say my
expression is put in parentheses so it's
cleaner so it's 2x plus 2 over X plus 1
so the first thing I would always try to
do is just say what happens if I just
stick X straight into this expression
what happens well what's 2x plus 2 when
X is equal to negative 1 it's 2 times
negative 1 2 times negative 1 plus 2
over negative 1 plus 1 well the
numerator is negative 2 plus 2 that
equals 0 over I what's the denominator
negative 1 plus 1 over 0 and do we know
what 0 over 0 is well no it's it's
undefined right so here's a case just
like what we saw in that first video
where the limit actually can't equal
what the expression equals when you
substitute X for the number you're
trying to find the limit of because you
get an undefined answer so let's see if
using the limit we can come up with a
with a better answer of what it's
approaching well since we're just
starting with these limit problems let
me draw a graph and I think this is
going to give you the intuition for what
we're doing and it'll probably give you
the answer and but then we'll show you
how to solve this analytically so if I
draw a graph these are the axes
actually probably I'll do the graphical
and the analytical at the same time so
I'm going to rewrite this expression in
a way that maybe I can simplify it so 2x
plus 2 isn't that the same thing as 2
times X plus 1 I see this pin this tool
2 times X plus 1 right 2x plus 2 is the
same thing it's 2 times X plus 1 and
then all of that is over all of that is
over X plus 1 so what as long as this
expression and this expression don't
equal 0 it actually turns out that this
function let's say this is f of X write
this function well for every value other
than X is equal to negative 1 you could
actually cancel this and this out and so
really we see that f of X is equal to I
need to find a better tool f of X is
equal to 2 when X does not equal
negative 1 and we saw when X is equal to
negative 1 it's undefined so undefined
undefined undefined when x equals
negative 1 so how would we graph that we
showed that F F f of X is equal to 2 and
X does not equal negative 1 and f of X
is undefined when x equals negative 1
and once again all I did is kind of
rewrite this exact same function right I
show that I could simplify and I could
divide the numerator and denominator by
X plus 1 as long as X does not equal
negative 1 and then otherwise it's
undefined so let me graph this I'm going
to get a different color maybe I'll go
with red so this is 2 so we see that X
is and the Moop say this is negative 1
so for every other value other than
negative 1 the value of this of f of X
is equal to 2 this is just you know this
is
one this is two this is three and one my
pin stops this is three so on
at negative one the graph is undefined
so there's a hole there and then we keep
going to the left-hand side so if we're
going to do the limit we can just
visually say well as X is let me do
another color now as X comes from the
left-hand side as X goes from this hand
side what is f of X equal well f of X is
2 2 2 2 2 f of X is equal to 2 until we
until we get to exactly negative 1 right
and similarly when we go from the other
hand it's the exact same thing f of X is
2 2 2 until we get to negative 1 so
you'll see I mean I make sure you see it
visually here that the limit of the
limit as X approaches negative 1 of 2 X
plus 2 over X plus 1 it equals 2 let me
draw a line here so you don't get messed
up with all them work and I'm not
formally I guess proving here that the
limit is 2 but I'm showing you kind of
an analytical and this is actually how
it tends to be done in algebra class is
that you tend to simplify the expression
so that you say oh if there wasn't a
hole here
what would the f of X equal right and
then you just evaluate it at that point
I think this might give you a little
intuition but this isn't this isn't a
formal solution but you unless you're
asked to you tend not to be asked for a
formal solution you actually just tend
to ask what the limit is and this is
where you could solve it and actually
another way that you could you can't I
mean I I often used to check my answers
when I used to do it is I mean you could
take a calculator and try in you know
what happens when what is f of minus
1.001
right and you could also try what is f
of point- 0.999 right because you what
you want to do is you want to say well
what is the function equal when I get
really close to negative 1 and then you
could keep going closer and closer to a
negative 1 and see what the function
approaches it in this case you'll see
that it approaches 2
so let's do another problem another
problem well let's say what is the limit
what is the my panel I'm going the wrong
layer what is the limit as X approaches
0 of 1 over X I think here it might be
useful to draw this this graph because
it'll give you a visual reason a visual
represent actually let's do it both ways
let's say let's do it the picking
numbers method because I think that'll
give you an intuition maybe it'll help
us draw the graph so let's say that this
is f of X let's say that f of X f of X
you can tell my presentation is very
unplanned f of X is equal to 1 over X
and we want to find the limit as X
approaches 0 so what is what is f of
what is actually let's make a table f of
X mmm this tool X so clearly when when X
is equal to 0 we don't know it's
undefined it's 1 over 0 is undefined
which is you know so we get we get
undefined but what happens when x equals
minus 0.01 well with minus 0.01 1 over
minus 0.01 that is equal to negative 100
all right what happens when X is equal
to minus 0.001 right so we're getting
closer and closer to 0 from the negative
direction well here it equals make sure
my pen is working color right
something's wrong with my tool my
computer is breaking down let's see
what's going on
and I think my computer just froze well
I'm going to try to solve this and in
the very next video I'm going to
continue on with this problem so I'll
actually see you in the next
presentation while I figure out why my
why my pen isn't working and then we'll
continue with this problem see you very
soon